welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel today's video is the third video
in the series of meta business Suite
videos and in today's version we're
going to talk about the meta business
weed Commerce the advertising and the
insights that you can get out of it
we're going to talk about what it is how
it works how do you use it what are the
pros what are the cons and I'll give you
some tips and tricks and we will talk
about what the future holds for The Meta
business manager now I'm Mark kman I'm
your digital navigator for this video
and as usual if you like the video then
subscribe to our Channel by clicking
down below but before we start let me
introduce something else to you if you
are in a position where you want to
upskill yourself whether you want to
master your digital marketing skills or
PL your dream job maybe grow your career
then you must explore simply learns
cohort of various digital marketing
programs we offer a we offer various
certification and post-graduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like Purdue
and like spj and meta and through our
courses you will gain the knowledge and
work ready expertise in skills like
cention Mark marketing strategies for
pay-per-click marketing analytics Roi
evaluating your digital marketing
campaign and many many others and that's
not all you will also get the
opportunity to work with some of the
industry experts on multiple projects
working in top tier companies and
lecturers from top
universities and after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a digital Market
marketing role either as a fresher or
moved on to a higher paying job and a
higher profile so if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out a link in
the pinned comment and description box
to find about what digital marketing
program works best for you now let's get
on with the
show but before delving into the details
let's talk about a pivotal role of the
meta business Suite the suite serves as
the central control hub for businesses
that use Facebook and Instagram and it's
more than just a tool it manages your
entire digital presence on Facebook and
Instagram no more need to use other
tools yeah you can now do it all within
the Facebook and Instagram world it's
essential for efficiency it consolidates
all the elements of your in your Faceook
Facebook and Instagram presence into one
unified dashboard it simplifies the
account management of your ad accounts
your pages and the team collaboration so
that only it does not only save you time
but it also reduces the complexity
allowing you to focus on what really
matters for you and that is your
business so it's a collaborative
workspace where you can enable your
colleagues to work with you as well on
your Facebook and your Instagram and
thereby it ensures that everybody is
lined contributing collectively to
achieving your business goals so it's a
suite of tool with lots of valuable
insights like audience management me
audience engagement metrics like ad
performance yeah and it is a One-Stop
shop to manage everything you need to do
uh in managing your Facebook and your
Instagram now we've been through various
um areas of it like we looked at the
dashboard we looked at the um posting
scheduling managing your content we
found a treasure of tools and
functionalities and in today's session
we're going to look at three specific
areas we're going to dive into the
Commerce manager and we're going to be
talking about some very important
changes that meta has announced in 2023
about managing your shop we're going to
look at Facebook and Instagram ads I'm
going to show you the process of
creating an ad and how to manage your
your audiences and then we're going to
conclude the video
with demo about the Facebook and meta
insights that you can
get right let's kick off demo one the
Commerce
manager now it's important to understand
that meta has made some very important
announcements in managing your Facebook
shop in response to the current economic
downturn meta is investing heavily in Ai
and automation tools to boost campaign
performance through shop advertising and
The Meta Advantage Suite of ads and
we'll come back to that in a little bit
yeah what that uh that means but it
means that shops
are scaling down in
functionality but promoting your
products through advertising is kind of
scaling up in um in Facebook and
Instagram so the shop ads are going to
be Consolidated Under The Meta advantage
and they facilitate easier shop setup
with inapp
checkout yeah so particularly for the
markets where you already have checkout
functionality within the Facebook app
yeah this is a very important
announcement that although the shop is
going to sort of De be defocused the
advertising of your products is going to
get more Center Stage
and thereby you can promote more of your
products to your target
audiences Now new shop tools that are
coming out like ratings reviews they're
being tested and support for shops
without checkout and that's very
important to understand if you haven't
got a checkout functionality in your
shop yeah and that will be in most of
the countries except in the US and I
believe in India the support for the
shops will be
discontinued with a focus on helping the
US businesses in adding the checkouts to
their existing shops basically what meta
is doing is to optimize the whole
shopping experience in the US market and
then rolling that out across other
markets which means that some of the
shop functionality and opening up a new
shopping Facebook in other markets like
Europe and like Asia is going to be
limited so this strategic change aims to
optimize the shopping experiences
support businesses and learn from the
experiences in the US before a global
roll out so remember as I said
discontinued support for shops without
checkouts in various markets like Europe
and Asia and and um for those markets
you can start focusing and focus
increase your focus on personalized ads
reels and messaging and in the US the
emphasis is on aiding businesses in imp
implementing the checkout with support
for shops linking to a website until
sort of first quarter of 2024 so now
this is clear let's start with looking
at the meta Commerce manager yeah the
Commerce manager is the essential core
of your online store and it simplifies
all your store tasks with a userfriendly
interface so it enables you to manage
your products to process your orders and
deliver excellent customer service to
your customers who buy your products Now
by centralizing all e-commerce
activities meta business Commerce
manager helps you to focus on selling
your product through Facebook and
Instagram and that is of course a
fantastic opportunity that you have to
add an additional sales channel to your
um your current sales
operation so let's get into the
demo so here we see the meta business
Suite portal and to get into the
Commerce manager we go to um down here
we look at all the tools
and then we see here down here the
Commerce button we click on there and
this takes you to the Commerce manager
interface and here is your
dashboard yeah so here you see the
overview but it gives you access to
activities like adding products to your
catalog like customizing your shop or
publishing your shop it gives you shop
insights it gives you things to do on
your catalog your shops offers that you
have it gives you your top products so
it gives you some basic insights it
gives you your top tagged content and
there may be some questions you have
that you can get answers from through
the
FAQ so here you see the
important elements of managing your shop
there is your catalog that's where you
start of course yeah there is the
different shops you may have and you can
manage your shops here you can run
promotions you can promote your product
through ads you can get insights you may
have a to-do list with things to
optimize your shop and here you go to
the
settings yeah of course always important
to start with the settings and you can
have a look at the details of your shop
there's the general settings of your
shop yeah like your account info like
your email there is your localization of
your shop but you can specify the
currency the language the product
details the shipping information you
have the settings for your catalog for
your business assets for your checkout
mid method permissions very important
you can assign permissions to different
users colleagues in your organization or
your agency yeah what they can do within
the Commerce manager and then there is
your customer support where you can uh
manage your claims your um charge back
email address details shop contact
information and what have you right so
that's important to understand all the
different items that you can go through
within your cont your Commerce manager
so let's go and have a let's add a
product yeah so first you're going to do
here to your back to your home to your
overview yeah and there are various ways
that you can start adding products to
your catalog yes so you can here add
products to your catalog directly here
yep and then there is the catalog menu
here where you can set items have
product sets the data sources where are
your products coming from yeah and then
there's the um the events as well that
you can
specify okay so let's go quickly here at
one item is very important that is the
data sources basically where are your
products coming
from yeah now here you get from your
current product catalog you see here
what the status is of your catalog yeah
and particularly when products come in
from a to um a Commerce site like
Shopify there may be issues with various
products that you name we need to have a
look at but here we can click on add an
item or add an item item here yes so I'm
just going to click here in general add
an item and here you see the different
ways that you can add a product it can
be done through a data feed it can be
done manually or it can be done through
a
pixel yeah that you can bring it in
through a pixel from another
website so look at the
manual yeah so if I'm just going to
click here on manual then here you see
the
manual let's have a look here you see
manual process for adding a
product yep so you can just click a new
item well here is an item you can add an
image for your item you can add a title
the description a website link the price
for your product you can add a sales
price a Facebook product category
condition of the product availability
the status yeah so lots of stuff that
you can add here for your product and
once you've done that yeah you then just
click upload
items so back in your dashboard you can
then click here on manage your catalog
and this is where you can see all the
products in your catalog and the status
and what the stock availability
and the price and of course if you have
hundreds of products you may want to set
some filters yeah check on attributes
for your
products yep so that is how you can man
add products to your catalog and how you
can manage your catalog as well so
another way to upload your items is
through a data feed and that's a very
important one yes so you can actually
just enter
Google Sheets Y and you can download in
a template of the format for the uh the
Google Sheets that you want to upload
with your product information but you
can also enter a URL from a server or a
hosting website and this URL is very
important when you want to work with
external Ecommerce stores like for
instance
Shopify the process there is that you
would um download kind of a a Facebook
app within your Shopify account and that
sets the connection with uh between
Shopify and the Facebook uh Commerce the
Facebook shop or there may be other the
e-commerce platforms where they will
actually give you a
URL and that's where you can add that
URL and that sets a link and the good
thing often about these Sol uh these
these Solutions is that there will be a
live link between your e-commerce
platform and your Facebook shop that
means when there is changes in your
product catalog in your e-commerce
platform it will automatically be
uploaded in your Facebook Commerce data
source or your Facebook Commerce catalog
right back to the overview so let's look
at how you can edit your shop now
remember the recent store changes yes so
in most markets you can no longer create
a new shop but you can edit an existing
shop and in some markets where there is
the inapp checkout functionality like in
the US you will still be able to create
new shops and manage your shops so let's
click here on shops and here you see the
shop that I have yep and it's um here I
can see the live
shop so here you see how the sh the shop
looks like y so um I can look at the
products and I can look at the
categories I can search within the shop
here you see a version
history yep or I can close this and I
can here I can edit my shop I can edit
the layout of the shop and I can edit
the settings of the
shop so here you see the homepage I can
look at collections I can optimize the
layout I can add banners for offers I
can add the Carousel of um of products
or collections to the Carousel and here
I can have suggestions for you yeah or a
dynamic product and it serves the
product that is relevant for the
customer yep but remember this is going
to scale down in the future yeah you
will no longer be able to see a shop and
actually on most sort of Facebook pages
you already see that many Facebook pages
have already removed the shop because of
the limited functionalities that you
have these
days okay so that is the shop that you
can um edit in the layout and here in
the settings you can edit the visibility
the inventory the website content the
categories yep and um again lots of
stuff that you can uh can manage
here the final thing we want to do in
the Facebook Commerce is to see how we
can do a promotion Y and if we go back
to the Commerce manager and the um the
dashboard of the Commerce manager we can
click here on
promotions and here you see
offers and this is where we can create
offers and we can see an overview of our
active offers our scheduled offers and
offers that that expired so let's have a
look at the create
offer functionality click on this and
here you can see your offer category so
I can have an amount of I can do a sale
I can do a free shipping I can do a buy
product X and get product y here's the
name of your offer and here you can see
the different if you want to use a promo
code if you don't want to use a promo
code then you tick this or you can get a
CO a code people have to enter and here
you see the summary of the offer so
we're going to give the name of the
offer is uh spring
promotion yeah no other changes it's an
automatic yes so no other details up
here to enter here we do the type are we
doing a percentage of or a flat amount
so let's say we're doing a
20% discount uh here you can select your
products we can say apply to the entire
shop or select some specific products
I'm going to do it for the entire shop
and then I can do include products that
already have a sales price or I cannot
include them the offer applies only once
per item or I can say let's do it per
order here you see what the offer would
look like yep and here you can set the
start date and the end date of your
offer if I'm happy with all these
settings I can then click here create
offer and then the offer will be live on
my
shop okay here is the summer uh sorry
here's the um the summary so the offer
has being created it gives you some some
tips so you can feature the offer in the
shop there's the offer
details yeah the discount ID the
visibility the start date we haven't
specified an end date yeah for all the
customers we can look at the customers
the product and then we see it's for all
products and then if we're happy with
this we'll just click cancel yeah so
that concludes the um the the promotion
and you see how simple it is to add a
promotion so now let's look at the last
section I want to cover in the Commerce
manager and that is the advertising that
you can schedule in the Commerce manager
now let's talk about Advantage Plus you
may have heard me talking about that
earlier in this video where it talks
about the um uh the changes that
Facebook announced in 2023 in the
Commerce manager so what are Advantage
Plus catalog ads they have been launched
on August the 15th in 2023 for
e-commerce and real retail advertisers
really helping them enhance the ad
efficiency so so the Advantage Plus ads
they use Ai and machine learning where
they automatically sort of create up to
150 creative combinations of the ads so
it eliminates manual steps in the ad
creation allowing advertisers to learn
much more efficiently how which ads work
and which acts don't work and how to
maximize their budget efficiently so the
roll out of Advantage Plus provides
advertisers with new and innovative ways
to optimize campaigns and thereby you
can get fantastic new insights that can
help in developing your advertising
strategies small businesses will also be
able to use Advantage Plus creative and
Advantage Plus audience to create ads
through their Facebook page so it's not
just through the Commerce manager but
small businesses can take advant AG of
it as well so it's about creating a
personalized audience based on your page
detail and automatically adjust over
time to help you reach more and relevant
customers for your um for your ads so
here you can see the what you can do so
if you want to get started with
Advantage catalog ads so you can add
your product you can set up tracking
through a pick
and then you can create your ad and if I
click on create ad you want to know
which ad account you would like to
advertise with and then you select the
in this case the Riad for Russia and
then that takes you to your advertising
setup and this basically is a um a
subset of the uh the Facebook or The
Meta advertising platform that we will
go through in a minute once we've
concluded the Commerce manager inter
section yep so that's um what I want to
say about the ads and then finally let's
look at the insights so here in the
insights you can get dat details
knowledge information about your catalog
your performance your audiences your
tagged content you can get in details
about awareness and there is the
helicopter overview of your shop
performance as well
well we had very little activity in our
shop because yeah we have a very
basically no real shop in this Facebook
account but here again you will get all
the details about your shop if you have
a full operating shop within the
Commerce
manager right that concludes the
Commerce manager so now let's look at
the advertising on Instagram and
Facebook that you can manage through
through the meta business suite and
we'll go there by various ways you can
go into the advertising yeah so Facebook
and or meta is very keen to get you to
advertise yeah you so you see in your
feed you see posts that you can boost um
here on the um the the basic menu you go
into advertising here if you click on
the all tools you can go to ads and
these are all subsections of what you
can do in the advertising if you really
want to go to the full advertising
platform of meta you click here on ads
manager this is the dashboard of your um
account in The Meta business Suite when
it comes to advertising you can see if
there are problems with your advertising
account there is the payment method that
you can set you can even create a
Facebook page from here you can verify
your email address and um here you have
access to the ads manager menu as well
and this is where you can have an
overview of your campaigns there is your
ads reporting very important section is
the audiences that you can create within
your ads manager and Target various
audiences with your ads there is in uh
billing and payments and your ad account
setting and here is an overview to all
the tools in the ad manager yeah
business settings um the integration
with the Commerce Center and lots of
other stuff when it comes to your uh
your ads in Facebook and Instagram so
let's go to the
campaigns yeah what we want to do is to
show you the powerful features in this
demo of the ads manager when it comes to
creating an ad in Facebook and in
Instagram yeah in this video to take you
through the entire ads manager that
would be um too long we'll do a separate
video on that but here I just want to
give you a quick highlight on how easy
it is to create a new campaign so here
you see the current campaigns that I
have here so now I'm not running any
campaigns they're all in draft mode but
here you see the typical structure for a
paperclick advertising campaign you have
campaigns under campaigns you have ad
sets and under ad sets you have ads and
the ads they inherit the settings of the
adets and the ad sets inherit the
settings of the campaign so in the
campaigns you would set your budget in
the adets you would set your taret
targeting and here are the specific ads
so it's all related to each other but
it's a multi-dimensional approach in
updating and managing your advertising
campaigns in um in meta so let's create
a new campaign and then you'll see how
it develops so we want first to look at
the campaign objective yeah so based on
what the objective for your campaign
meta will come back to you with the
ideal settings for that particular
objective so it could be lead generation
it could be engagement it could be
driving traffic like sending people to a
destination like your website or an app
or your Instagram profile great for
getting link clicks landing page views
Etc so let's click on traffic and here
I'm going to continue so now it's going
to ask me a number of
questions yes so and I just have to go
through those questions when it comes
for the campaign when it comes to the ad
set and when it comes to the ad yeah so
we have the campaign name we have the
special ad categories if you want to do
yeah so there are special categories
that Facebook or meta wants to know
about whether it's related to credit and
M social issues elections yeah because
there may be different requirements this
was sort of set up after the um I think
it were the 2018 elections in the US and
the brexit um elect sort of um uh poll
uh on how advertising was kind of abused
to reach audiences with kind of false
information so now when you do advertise
for social issues and elections or
politics then there are very specific
requirements yeah but we say there're
not applicable here we go to the
campaign
details yeah I can edit this the buying
type is an auction so the highest bidder
with the best quality ad will get the
best position for the ad you can do you
can change this as well uh you can do by
auction or by reservation but that is
where you will have to pay more yep and
then here's the campaign objective that
we've set at the beginning of the
process which is objective of traffic
yeah you can then set do you want to do
testing for your
ad yep and you will let Facebook create
different versions of your ad and then
it will run the different versions and
it will look at what ad will give the
best performance and do you want to make
it an advanced campaign budget yes so it
will distribute your budget across
current currently delivering adets to
get more results yeah but I'm going to
leave that off and I'm going to click to
next so that's my campaign settings
we're then going to the ad set and in
the ad set you're going to look at your
conversion location would that be your
website or a landing page an app on
messenger or your Instagram profile so
let's send traffic to my
website yeah and then here you see your
estimated daily results how many people
you will reach and how many link clicks
I'm going to set the performance goal I
want to maximize the number of
clicks yeah what would I want to do yeah
to spend what do I want to spend
basically I can say I'm going to spend
let's say um
one dollar or one pound in in this case
per result call I can have more options
here I can say different bit strategies
that I can have yeah I can say what is
the maximum spend or what is the cost
per result call what am I prepared to
spend per kind of um click as it were
yeah I'm going to leave at that and here
you have Dynamic
creative yeah I can also leave this
blank by the way because I have my
budget setting further down below so
Dynamic creative I would just provide
creative elements such as images and
headlines and then meta will
automatically generate the perfect ads
for you a very interesting um process um
I'm going to leave it off for now
because I want to show you how an ad may
look like and how you can develop that
so my daily budget I'm setting it at 20
a day yep here's the start date and I
can set an end date yeah so I'm going to
set the star date a bit further yeah
because I don't want it to start and
send a tar date don't need to send an
end date yep and here is the budg and
scheduling you can now schedule budget
and greases on certain days I'm not
going to do that at the start of the
campaign because I want Facebook or meta
in this case decide what works best for
me yep so and then add scheduling I can
specify but again I'm going to run all
the ads at the same time and then here
you have your audience controls so this
is set criteria for where ADS can be
delivered so this is we have sort of
location we have age we can look at
existing custom audiences that we have
created over time I can look at audience
suggestions yep so um so that is part of
the Advantage Plus audience that I
created that I discussed with you
earlier yep and here you have your
placements and there is let meta decide
for you where your ad is going to be
shown or you can decide for manual
placement yep and then is the more
placement you select the better it is
yeah but we let the Advance Plus yeah
show more options here there's brand
safety and suitability Pro for instance
prevent your ads from appearing near
content that's not conducive to your
brand for instance if you are a holiday
destination and you advertise on
Facebook you don't want to be shown um
next to an article or a a post about um
about an airline disaster yes so we're
going to hide these options manual
placements I also want you to be aware
where you can select which platforms do
you want to advertise on Facebook
Facebook's Audience Network on Instagram
or on messenger shop is no longer
available we talked about that yep and
here you go then in your ad so this is
the placement of the ads where do you
want to show your ads in the feeds in
the stories instream ads the search
results in messages but again we'll let
Facebook or meta decide on all of this
okay so I'm going back to Advantage Plus
placement where you use Facebook's
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to give you the best placement
based on meta's understanding of your um
your audience so click next yep and then
is um we're going to go to the ad yeah
so Facebook suggest make a carousel ad
yeah so here we go into
the um the ad creation so the Facebook
page that we're going to base this on is
let me have a look R for
Russia yeah we're going to manually
upload creatives or we can get it from
the catalog yeah and here you see your
preview these are the products for my
catalog yes so I'm just going to leave
it for this product for now yes so so
you're going to look at the format I
wanted a
carousel now I have two products in my
Carousel so they should probably come up
now yeah so um so here is the second
product no yeah so but that's how it
would look like or you can do a
collection you can do multi- Advertiser
ads so and I can um have the catalog for
the ad creative as I said could be a
product set I have multiple productss I
can make Carousel cards as well yeah I
can turn it in a slideshow lots and lots
of opportunities and here you have your
headline and your description yeah so
the headline is carpet I can take that
out I can say um spring
promotion sort of Atlas
mountains
carpet yeah so that should now be added
here under the um the ad and here you
see shop now button I can add the
description that will show up at the uh
the top describe your link which would
be
fantastic handmade car
carpets from the
barbers in the Atlas
Mountains let's
see yeah on bigger ads you see that that
would show up here at the um the front
so yep and then you are um basically
having your price memory text let me
have a look I think that is actually the
text that I wanted up
here let me have a look at
that there it is yeah so that is the
text that I wanted there and here the
call to action that would be shop now
but I have a whole range of call to
actions yeah so keep that as shop now
then where do I drive people to I drive
them to my shop and that is the website
do I want to build a URL par parameter
so I can track my campaign in the uh in
in
analytics yeah I'm not going to set it
up I can choose an app if I want to so
lots of stuff that I can do here I can
set up the tracking through the re pixel
I can select a pixel I'm not going to go
into those details and here is the URL
parameter that I want to build for the
tracking but here is the basic version
of my ad yeah and now it's a matter of
pressing publish and then the next thing
that will happen that Facebook will look
at the ad they will evaluate the ad and
once they approve the ad yeah then the
campaign will go live yep so here's the
business location and currency I'm just
clicking next that's the payment
information they still need my credit
card details I don't want to do that
yeah so I'm not going to give them the
details so I want to skip that so I'm
not going to publish this campaign for
now but at least it gives you an
overview of how to create a campaign in
the flow of campaign ad set and ads
there's a lot more to it obviously but
at least this gives you a high level
overview so if that is on the campaign
setting there are two more important
areas that is your audience
creation so you can create separate
audiences that you can then add as an
audience for your ad campaign yes so if
you click create you can create a custom
audiences a lookalike audience or what
we say a saved audience yeah if I click
on Saved audience what you're going to
do you can specify the audience with the
name yeah and by the location but you
can then do a detailed targeting based
on demographics interests or behaviors
so I can just click here let's say
somebody who is excited about travel
yeah so could be frequent
Travelers yeah and there's a whole range
of uh things that you can add here and
in your um your audience and you will
see that it will in sort of impact your
audience size as well so you can do by
Behavior yeah or by uh by interest so um
and there's a whole sort of let's say I
want to do
California yeah so I can California
place people who are either interested
there yeah so I can Target by location
as well if I want so this is the really
powerful um aspect of paperclick
campaigns on meta and also on Google
yeah on the targeting so I'm going to
cancel this I can also create an
audience let we say a custom audience
and this is uh these are audiences based
on people who have done a specific
behavior like visiting your website and
this is what we call the retargeting so
Facebook allows you to Target people who
have visited your website a particular
page which means the next day they could
get an advert of your Facebook ad of the
the product that they saw on your
website so it's all to do with the
retargeting and the pixel marketing now
I'm not going to go into that because
that's beyond the scope of this video
but this is where you would set it all
up okay and then of course within your
advertising you have your ads reporting
section as
well
where you can look at the account name
yeah for the um yeah you can look at
reach Impressions frequency amount spent
and attribution setting now I haven't
got any campaigns running so I don't see
any details here yeah also because the
period is but let's say if we can
select um let me have a look let's say
no I haven't run any Facebook campaigns
on this campaign so I can't show you any
data but this is where you can create
your advertising reports where you can
select all these breakdowns and bring
them into your
report good that's it on the Facebook
and Instagram
ads and what we're going to do now is
move to the next demo the final demo of
this series which is everything to do
with the meta insights to access the
insights in the metab business Suite you
go to the main dashboard and you click
on all
tools and you scroll down in analyzing
and Reporting so you have your specific
ads reporting you can create tests like
experiments yeah that you can get
reports on you can get traffic analysis
yeah so um Trends are related to the
Facebook Impressions and use it
of the website or app and you can go
into the Insight section where you learn
about um about it your your Facebook
page and about Trends and activities and
engagement around your activities on
Instagram and on Facebook so here you
see the summary your last week in review
so you see the reach from last week on
my Facebook and Instagram
the total for this week your messaging
activity how you're uh progressing
towards goals that you've specified like
increase reach for instance and here you
see your activity the content that we
placed and how uh and if we did any
advertisement so that is sort of your
high level summary if you click here on
view all insights you're going to your
dashboard yeah so let start and have a
look at this dashboard this is where you
get a very detailed breakdown into your
audiences yes so you can understand your
audience's characteristics and behaviors
and you can develop your content
strategies for a more personalized and
engaging customer experience so let's
look at the most important reports here
on your dashboard you get per
performance information on content
interaction on reach on followers link
clicks and minutes viewed of um your
page and you scroll down yeah you can
see advertising what you've done or what
others have done and your post frequency
this is where you can help you what you
should do to grow your uh your reach and
obviously Facebook will say hey you need
to start advertising and post more so
boost for reach takes you straight into
the advertising or create post takes you
to your uh your content and your post
and scheduling section within uh The
Meta business Suite so very important
here and that is the most important
reports in your uh Insight which is your
audience report which is your content
report and your performance perance
report yeah so let's have a look at
these three reports and see what we get
if I look at audience here again you can
go straight into advertising or creating
a post but what you want to have here
want to look at is how did my followers
grow yeah and how did on both Facebook
and on
Instagram yeah what are the most
important cities where people are from
yeah that are um following our page what
are the top
countries yeah so lots of information
you get here and then the age and the
gender so that's your current audience
it gives you potential audience where
what you can get yeah the top
cities top countries top other pages
that you can learn
from yeah so great information that you
can get here on your audience that you
are interacting with if we then look at
your content yeah to me this is probably
the most important section of your meta
insights here you see what content works
and what doesn't work yeah for your
Facebook post your stories and your
Instagram post and stories whether those
posts are photos or videos or text posts
yeah so here you have your level
overview of you can select for Facebook
or Instagram you see the reach and the
engagement but the real spicy details
you can find under content here you can
see every post and story and video that
you did yeah and you can see here what
is the title what is the date published
and what else you can see here is
information about reach and impressions
and further details that you get yeah so
and this makes it so exciting because
here you can see which posts have the
highest engagement levels like reactions
like comments and shares and you can
order these from high to low so I can
now see what post has been my most
engaging post when it comes to reactions
in the last 28 days I can say make that
in the last 90
days yeah I can now see what has been my
most popular post over the last 90 days
when it comes to reactions and comments
and share and the nice thing then is by
clicking on that post you see what the
post was about and then you can say hey
if that post worked then can we make the
other post similar to to this post
because for this post we know that that
post Works yep so very useful
information you can get here about your
content and use that to your advantage
yeah so we looked at the audience we
looked at the content so now let's look
at the performance of the videos and the
reals again I can see a summary I can
also go down straight into the
details yep and here you see total
minutes of few
um compared to the previous period you
see what is organic what is paid and
again what were your most import the
most popular posts when it comes to
minutes
viewed yeah for the the period that you
selected so here in the send some final
details about your
audience yeah for your your videos and
the retentions now we haven't got any
earnings on videos so that kind of
summarizes everything there is to know
about the insights a fantastic pool of
data that you can use to kind of look at
Trends yeah so you can kind of predict
of what is going to happen and you can
stay ahead of the curve with what you
learn from your meta insights so very
useful and um take this uh information
and turn that into your advantage by
creating better posts targeting better
audiences and thereby getting better
results right that's a wrap let me
summarize what have we been through in
this video we looked at the Commerce
manager we looked at the Facebook and
Instagram in uh ads and we looked at the
insights that you you get and this is
the um the conclusion of our three video
series on meta business Suite I hope you
found it useful stay tuned for more
information for more videos we will go
deeper into the various topics in the
next few months and so you get an even
better understanding of what you can do
with the meta business Suite now if you
want to know more of course check out
all the other simply learned courses as
well well and if you like the video then
click on the button below yeah subscribe
to our channel so you can take advantage
of um all the learnings that we have
here and you will get notifications of
new videos that we published so for now
for me that's it and I wish you a good
day and I see you at the next
video staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here